my husband was the furthest thing from a  rockstar junkie  he just wasn't he was the best husband  the greatest father I lost my soulmate  and love of my life he wanted to be  there for his family for his children he  loved his life he loved his you know he  would never have ever left this world  and you believe it was the addiction  that led him to do what he did that  night in taking his life I don't think  that he could make any decisions because  of the level of impairments I know that  people say you know you can't blame  yourself and you know I'm trying not to  but there were signs you can't blame  yourself Vicki you relapse after cancer  I had a relapse and nobody questioned it  why is it when you have an addiction  which is an illness why is it any  different it's not people think that  addiction is like oh you were an addict  and people don't recognize that as a  disease and I was I feel guilty of the  same thing  you think intention is a choice and it's  not  you